house prices are going to go up every  year for the next five years how do you  know if you're ready to buy a house  because if you're ready to buy a house  you need to buy now all right here's how  you know if you're ready you're out of  debt you have an emergency fund of three  to six months of expenses and you have a  good strong down payment twenty percent  is preferable because you avoid pmi if  you're a first-time home buyer sometimes  you only put down five percent or ten  percent that's okay but you're going to  pay that stinking pmi get ready then  when you buy you buy on a 15-year fixed  where the payment is no more than a  fourth of your take-home pay well i  can't afford the house i like that's got  the granite countertops then you can't  afford that house hello you need to buy  a house you can afford that's a good  wise financial decision and you need to  buy now house prices are not going down